soy justiniano lic y soy un ilusionista
psicológico eso significa que hoy no voy
a estar haciendo juegos de manos ni
ilusiones ópticas porque no me interesa
engañarlos los ojos
hoy o intentar engañar lees algo más
fundamental y para hacerlo me va a valer
de algunas herramientas pero también de
algunos juguetes siendo el primero de
ellos el juguete más conocido de todos
el cubo de rubik el cubo de rubik
contiene 43 trillones de combinaciones
posibles y se lo voy a dar
como es tu nombre
leandro le podrías pasar esto a leandro
te voy a pedir leandro que sin romperlo
lo desarmes hasta que esté satisfecho y
me esperes hasta el final que te voy a
pedir que te unas conmigo acá en el
escenario para devolverme lo puede ser
le damos un fuerte aplauso a leandro
el segundo juguete que vamos a usar hoy
es este la baraja francesa nutria que
levanten la mano todas las mujeres que
tengan calculadora el celular
como es tu nombre
agustina
te voy a dar la baraja quiero que por
favor la saques de la caja las mezclas
y cuando termines la vas a volver a
guardar la caja me vas a espera hasta el
final que te voy a pedir que te unas
conmigo con el escenario para devolverme
la puede ser veamos un fuerte aplauso
agustín a
el tercer elemento que vamos a utilizar
hoy para jugar
para eso le voy a entregar esta libreta
a uno de mis asistentes que va a
pedirles a cuatro personas distintas del
público que escriban ahí cuatro números
de cuatro cifras le damos un fuerte
aplauso él
[Aplausos]
les prometo que todo esto va a tener
sentido al final
por ahora les cuento que la propuesta es
que nos tomemos un recreo de nuestras
ataduras cotidianas y que este sea un
momento en el cual ustedes simplemente
puedan dejarse llevar y puedan creer en
lo que ustedes quieran creer por
supuesto que ustedes podrían decirme
bueno pero es una mentira porque cuando
termine vamos a volver al mundo real y
tendrían razón
o quizás
o quizás sea como se suele decir que el
arte miente para decir la verdad
entonces quizás la mentira que estamos a
punto de contar nos tenga más de verdad
que la misma realidad
hoy vamos a jugar con esa parte de
nosotros que es irracional mágica e
intuitiva vamos a adentrarnos en este
lugar completamente misterioso que es el
que rige nuestras creencias y nuestra
personalidad
por supuesto que esto no se va a tratar
de exponer o avergonzar a nadie pero sí
vamos a jugar un poquito con esta idea
de una fuerza invisible tan poderosa
como es nuestra imaginación y para
hacerlo les propongo que hagamos un
juego un juego el cual pueden participar
de sus asientos así que si quieren
hacerlo le voy a pedir que pongan ambos
pies en el piso ahora muy bien tomen una
respiración profunda
durante el transcurso de este juego les
voy a pedir que cierren los ojos
también durante el transcurso de este
juego yo voy a bajar del escenario y voy
a acercarme a uno de ustedes y lo voy a
tocar el hombro
esto no significa me estoy poniendo raro
lo único que significa es que con ese
toque estoy invitando a esa persona y no
a otra a unirse conmigo en el escenario
con una experiencia similar ok
según ustedes siente que yo le toco las
manos es para que abran los ojos y me
dejen pasar porque en realidad quiero
acceder a otra persona
el ejercicio que vamos a hacer es muy
simple todos así como están con los pies
en el piso me gustaría que extiendan las
manos así en frente de ustedes o bien
más o menos a la altura de los hombros
palmas enfrentadas midan con la mirada
la distancia que entre sus manos
tomen una respiración profunda ahora y
cierren los ojos
me gustaría que se imaginen que las
palmas de sus manos son dos imanes muy
poderosos
empiezan a atraer entre sí cada vez más
y siempre que sus manos atraen se mueven
se pegan no se tocan para permitir que
esto suceda
me gustaría que respiren profundamente y
noten como con cada respiración la
fuerza de sus imanes aumenta el doble el
triple cada vez más lo están haciendo
muy bien el momento voy a comenzar a
contar desde 5 hasta 1 y cuando termine
de contar si sus manos no se pegaron se
van a terminar de pegar la quieren
profundamente
más
y más eso es muy bien
5 cada vez más y más fuerza sus imanes 4
eso es permitiendo que eso suceda lo
están haciendo muy bien
3 cada vez más y más juntas las manos
dos respiren profundamente una vez más
pueden abrir los ojos y ver hasta donde
llegaron
pueden darse ustedes mismos un fuerte
aplauso
siempre que hago este ejercicio me
encuentro con tres tipos de personas el
primero están así con las manos
extendidas los ojos cerrados y yo veo
que hacen esto
y ya sé que no están escuchando nada de
todo lo que estoy diciendo el segundo
tipo de personas tiene las manos así
extendían los ojos cerrados ellos hace
que por dentro están pensando son mis
manos yo lo que quiera con mis manos
y el tercero son mis favoritos y muy
buenos quiero pasar esos me encantan sin
embargo hay una persona entre ustedes
que no hizo ninguna de esas tres cosas
que simplemente se dejó llevar por la
idea y eso creo que le dio un muy buen
resultado le voy a pedir a esa persona
que se ponga de pie que le toque el
hombro estaba por allá atrás muy bien
cómo te llamas
valentina te animarías a subir al
escenario le damos un fuerte aplauso
[Aplausos]
qué te parece acá por favor
mirándome y les pido disculpas por
adelantado porque por un ratito no les
voy a estar hablando directamente
ustedes y si voy a estar hablando con
ellas les pido por favor que hagan
silencio les prometo que estamos yendo a
un lado con todo esto
me gustaría porque antes tus piezas y
eso es bien y comienza a respirar
profundamente por la nariz
eso es continuo haciendo esto mientras
te voy a explicar lo siguiente en el
momento todavía no por un momento vamos
a hacer un ejercicio muy similar lo que
vamos a hacer durante el cual vas a
mantener los ojos abiertos y vas a
encontrarte con resultados similares la
única diferencia es que durante el
transcurso este ejercicio puedes
escuchar que yo tengo la palabra sueño
eso significa que te estoy invitando en
este momento y no en otro a entrar a lo
que se entiende como un estado de trance
en ese momento vas a sentir que se te
relaja todo el cuerpo se te vencen las
rodillas se te cierran los ojos y eso
está bien en su momento tienes dos
opciones puedes abrir los ojos y decirte
lo que te quiere decir a vos misma hoy
la medida esto no es para mí me
desconcentré o simplemente puedes cerrar
los ojos y dejarte llevar te prometo que
voy a poner lo mejor de mí para que
tengas una experiencia lo más lindo
posible
muy bien vamos a empezar jugando nada
más
así como estás poner las manos ahora
montado el cuerpo y eso es bien debe
empezar a balancear quiero que se
presente y que parece libro pongas el
pie
bien muy bien
[Música]
lo que sea
que tal vez las tribus hablan de una
respiración profunda
[Música]
eso es muy bien entonces yendo muy bien
lo que pasa es que la profundo
[Música]
abiertos completamente relajado abrazo
pero profundamente una vez más
otra vez debajo del brazo
fijo
completamente relajado dejándote llevar
cada vez más
relajada cada sonido externo que sentís
cada cosa que escuchas lleva el doble el
triple de profundo en un momento de
comenzar a contar de 5 hasta 1 con cada
número va a ser el doble el triple de
profundo eso es
simplemente dejándote llevar caso y
externo escuchas 5 cada cosa que sentís
4 se lleva el doble
el triple de profundo eso es 3
s
a partir de ahora cada vez que yo diga
la palabra sueño con la intención de
volverte a hacer entrar en trance vamos
a entrar el doble el triple de profundo
[Música]
a la cuenta de tres y solamente a la
cuenta de tres vas a abrir los ojos uno
dos tres
[Música]
información
seguí mis dedos con la cabeza muy
rápidamente muy rápidamente como rápida
y profundamente
las más rápidas
eso es
el pecho
no te llevará cada vez más 5
relajación es total
y mantengan los ojos cerrados durante
toda la experiencia hasta que yo te pida
que lo sabrás
lo estás haciendo muy
pero muy muy bien cada vez más
más relajada eso es cada vez más
y más profundamente relajada eso es lo
estás haciendo perfectamente
completamente relajada de eso es cada
vez más y más profundamente relajada
en el momento voy a levantar tu mano
izquierda y voy a poner un pizarrón en
tus piernas creo que simplemente me
permitas apoyarlo ahí y aprietes hacia
abajo con fuerza con mucha fuerza de eso
es
no estás haciendo muy bien
eso es la otra mano completamente
relajada absolutamente relajada
eso es voy a poner una tiza en esta mano
y quiero que le sostengas con fuerza eso
es muy bien yo la voy a apoyar
simplemente sobre la superficie de la
pizarra eso es muy bien simplemente
dejándote llevar lo estás haciendo
excelente
me gustaría que tomes una respiración
profunda y comiences a mover la tiza por
la superficie de la pizarra de un lugar
a otro pensando en lo que sea que
necesite 5 quiero que te imagines una
idea perseguida puede ser cualquier cosa
quiero que quiero que se te ocurra una
idea una idea cualquiera y empieces a
dibujar dibujes una línea una línea muy
rápido en el cerca de cerca del centro
eso es muy bien lo estás haciendo muy
bien
dibuja dibuja una línea una línea más
rápida como más fuerte eso eso eso cada
vez más muy bien
lo está haciendo muy bien y dibuja otra
línea en otra parte por completo
distinta de la pizarra en otra parte
distinta por completo
muy bien stop
creo que esto es muy interesante entre
que respire profundamente y a la cuenta
de tres y solamente la cuenta de tres
vas a abrir los ojos sintiéndote muy
bien respira profundo una vez más y 1 2
tres ojos abiertos
ponentes bien no muestre todavía para
tallar a la cuenta de tres y solamente
la cuenta de tres
quiero que muestra
gracias por participar puedes volver a
tu lugar le damos un aplauso fuerte a
ella
[Aplausos]
lo que quiero compartir con ustedes a
continuación tiene que ver con
desarrollar ese potencial que todos
tenemos pero que la mayoría ignoramos
me parece importante recordar que dentro
de cada persona hay un universo
misterioso de capacidades por explorar
pero como no podría pedirles a ustedes
que lo hagan si yo no lo hiciera primero
les voy a mostrar uno de los resultados
de haber emprendido esa búsqueda
ojalá que además entretenerlos los
inspira seguir buscando
cuando comenzamos entregué un cubo de
rubik y yo más o descartarlos pudiera
decir que se unan conmigo que en el
escenario vamos a darles un fuerte
aplauso ellos dos
gracias porque te parece
[Aplausos]
qué tal muy bien vamos a hacer lo
siguiente
también del lugar por favor no me
traigas estés a mi derecha izquierda
perdón dice muerte de más muy bien
cuatro personas distintas escribieron
cuatro números de cuatro cifras acá
verdad levanten la mano por favor bien
excelente lo que vamos a hacer es muy
simple música maestro ustedes van a
ayudar a terminar con este ratito que
estamos compartiendo así que primero les
voy a contar lo que yo voy a hacer y
sportivo explicar lo que tienen que
hacer ustedes que es muy importante
acérquese por favor
póngase mirando para mí
lo que voy a hacer yo es lo siguiente
voy a memorizar el mazo de cartas en el
orden nuestras puede memorizar el cubo
de rubik en el orden
y voy a memorizar los cuatro números en
cuatro personas los ojos vendados
mientras digo todas las cartas y al
final de eso voy a decir cuánto da la
suma de los cuatro números de posiciones
y varias personas
la parte más fácil tu trabajo es el
siguiente
a medida que eso lo diga
y de picas de corazones este seguro que
yo lo ves rápido entonces es importante
que me escuches para poder mostrarlas
tu trabajo es un poquito más difícil
debe entregar este anotador que tengas
para abajo todavía no mires yo lo voy a
ver justo antes de venderme los ojos tu
trabajo ahora es sumar esos cuatro
números de cuatro cifras en tu cabeza
asegurarte que tiene la cuenta y después
chequear las ayudas pero tenés encima
así que te pido por favor que parece acá
un contrato y que empieces a hacer eso
[Música]
finalmente te voy a dar esto necesito
que guardes
[Música]
es
un ratito
entre tener muerto
[Música]
me vende los ojos quiero que escribas el
resultado que es en la parte que está en
blanco de la pizarra y esperes al final
hasta que yo lo diga
para mostrarlo
solamente para chequear aunque no sé de
qué me serviría quiero que te acerque
por favor dijo robert es que a través de
esta banda no se puede ver nada
les dio acercar los ojos
abierto
quiero que me muestre la libreta por
favor
[Música]
también
si mi mente
mira
[Música]
muy bien
escucha bien ahí
[Música]
quiero que me confirme que hay color
blanco
y acá debería haber color verde
y ahí agarro
excelente muy bien
voy a comenzar con las cartas música
maestro
las cartas son 4 de trébol rey de picas
de corazones
10 de trébol reina de trébol 2 de picas
y 6 de trébol
e
3 de picas rey de diamantes 9 de
diamantes
[Música]
desde corazones no del trébol 4 de picas
y 4 de diamantes 6 de picas siete
corazones tres de trébol y siete de
picas y diez de picas as de diamantes a
diamantes y ocho de diamantes
los tres de corazones donde entregó el 5
de trébol y 7 de trébol
[Música]
6 de diamantes y reina de corazones as
de trébol
[Música]
cuatro corazones dos de corazones sin
poder picar nueve de picas diez
diamantes a de corazones
[Música]
7 de diamantes 5 diamantes y 3 de
diamantes
tres diamantes tiene el rey de tréboles
y el as de picas las de picas
6 de corazones y jota de corazones 8 de
picas y 8 de corazones después de los
corazones bien en él
dos diamantes y reina de diamantes y
jota de tréboles
y poder de policía
[Música]
reina de picas
y 8 de tréboles y porta diamantes
y nueve corazones hijos de tréboles y
éstas deberían ser todas las cartas de
la baraja francesa
[Música]
debería
esto
v rubik debería estar armado ahora
[Música]
y el resultado de la suma de los cuatro
números de cuatro cifras es 22 mil 50
[Música]
[Aplausos]
lo que
bueno
lo que les acabo de compartir
a mí me recuerda
dentro de cada persona hay un universo
de capacidades por explorar y espero que
esto por lo menos les haya avivado la
curiosidad por ustedes mismos y el mundo
que los rodea
gracias por jugar conmigo
[Aplausos]